[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau 7,8 sport
le troisième de la saison
le magazine est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département à ces parties a pour le
sommaire tennis l'open de plaisir était
programmée la semaine dernière ce
tournoi future est considéré comme le
troisième plus gros rendez-vous en
ile-de-france derrière roland garros et
bercy la finale s'est soldée ce dimanche
par la victoire dans le tableau masculin
du conseil wang
plus de détails dans ce magazine course
à pied a le paris versailles a fêté
cette année son quarantième anniversaire
puis de 25 mille coureurs se sont
inscrits pour la compétition cette année
plus d'informations à suivre
rugby le championnat de division honneur
reprend ce week-end le sky rugby promu
cette année dans cette division va
tenter de se maintenir pour le parler de
l'effectif des objectifs et du premier
match de la saison contre les ménages
recevront le président guillaume payen
les trois quarts centre à alexandre
meunier on commence tout de suite par
l'actualité sportive du week end
du tennis pour commencer ce magazine la
semaine dernière le tennis-club de
plaisir à organiser la 27e édition de
son tournoi futures à la clé une
dotation de 25 mille dollars plus de 600
joueurs et 5000 spectateurs ont répondu
présent à montage de examen c'est le
troisième plus gros tournoi de tennis en
ile-de-france la 27ème édition de l'open
de plaisir se déroule jusqu'au 24
septembre tennis club de la commune
cette année plus de 600 joueurs venus de
toute l'europe s'affrontent sur les
clubs les marchands très disputée les
joueurs ça vaut gagner quelques points
atp qui vont leur permettre de défaire
des trois challengers demain et peut
être demain des grands chelems
donc tout ça c'est une évidence et c'est
pour cette raison que ce tournant après
bien c'est le support de haut niveau qui
a son visage naturel si je puis dire
avec sa dotation à 25000 dollars le
rendez-vous est intégré au futur la 6è
catégorie des tournois de tennis
déjà on a des arbitres on a déjà tout
dit après ça un futur en à des
changements de balle on a des serviettes
des bouteilles d'eau ça a fait on est un
peu comme un sur un mini mini roland
università aussi ses versements chapa et
on essaie des récom des très bons
joueurs donc ça fait toujours plaisir
sur le plan sportif le tournoi est
réputé pour faire éclore des talents
l'événement a révélé de nouveaux
professionnels tricolore c'est quoi les
futurs champions de demain
lee chong aller mahut et cetera les
lieux dry compagnies sont passés par là
donc nous avons les futurs champions de
demain
la future pépite du tennis français se
trouvaient peut-être sur les courts
pendant cette édition les 5000
spectateurs présents pourront peut-être
sont vantés dans le quelques années et
le tournoi de plaisir s'est clôturé ce
dimanche 24 septembre par la finale du
tableau masculin le français antoine
guang 21 ans tête de série numéro 6 a
remporté la finale contre le hollandais
sijsling issu des qualifications après
avoir perdu le premier set 4 à 6
sportifs tricolores remportent les deux
sets suivants 6 3 6 4
un match à l'image de cette 27e édition
qui a été très disputée sur les courts
de plaisir on écoute le président du
club charles giordanno au micro de tv 78
je veux pas commencer à citer les noms
mais vous avez encore une finale
exceptionnelle avec le néerlandais qui a
été sacré deux septièmes mondiales
et puis notre espoir national le petit
wang antoine donc nous assistons ici à
une finale au sida d'un très très bon
cru et
franchement je suis ravi chez les filles
ségolène berger ex 180e mondial 35 ans
s'est imposé contre mais la ser 6 3 6 2
en finale
un mot de course à pied à présent avec
la mythique course paris-versailles la
compétition qui relie la tour eiffel à
la cité royale fêté cette année son
quarantième anniversaire au total 25
millins courageux se sont inscrits pour
ce 16 km les images sont signés à
patrick jacques de dixmude dimanche 24
septembre 10h25 mille concurrents ont
pris le départ de la 40e édition du
paris versailles au niveau du tracé pas
de changement en 2017 ce 16 km relie
comme chaque année la tour eiffel à la
cité royale en passant par me do et la
redoutable côte des gardes
peu importe l allure à laquelle on va on
est toujours en difficulté dans la côte
des gardes ce qu'on perd un peu de
vitesse après faut relancer mais c'est
une super course un super parcours les
supporters géniaux et donc moi j'ai
adoré cette course et e et un port pci
classique des autres parce que c'est une
course de deux villes et à la forme à
100 livres face en forêt on a de la
cause du décès
c'est la meilleure course parisienne
pour s'entraîner chez les garçons
l'éthiopien getty neigé d'amour remporté
cette 40e édition les réalise un temps
de 52 minutes et 50 secondes le premier
français est thierry qu'il botham
deuxième en 53 minutes et 12 secondes
après avoir mené une grande partie de la
course toujours déçu de finir 2e est
déjà en arrivant ici je pensais pas que
la deuxième
il est plus fort il faut l'accepter mais
je suis très heureux d'avoir fait 13e
derrière lui se tient c'est bien c'est
très bien
l'ethiopie réalise le doublé avec la
victoire de schalke zidane et gaza en 58
minutes et 13 secondes chez les
féminines la sportive devance la
française garance blot de près de deux
minutes
je suis absolument ravi et ce n'est pas
un objectif donc c'est une super
surprise en rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une 41e édition la
compétition devrait une nouvelle fois
attiré 25 mille concurrents sur les
organisateurs ce qui fait du paris
versailles l'une des courses les plus
suivis en ile de france
on ouvre à présent une page football ce
samedi les réserves de caen et d'auxerre
qui évoluent toutes les deux en
nationale 3 se sont affrontés dans un
match amical organisé au stade
guy-boniface d'elancourt l'occasion de
voir notamment à l'oeuvre l'ancien élan
courtois françois-xavier fou ou tamudo
aujourd'hui joueur professionnel chez
les bourguignons à 22 ans
notre journaliste patrick jacques de
dixmude est monté à dans les tribunes
pour recueillir les réactions
mais en fait c'est un petit jeune qui a
commencé dans le football avec mon
frangin mon petit frère
et voilà depuis on le suit et puis on
l'apprécié ce qui fait quoi bah écoutez
c'est époustouflant du coup on a la
chance d'aller voir les matches à
auxerre et franchement avoir suivi sa
carrière et pouvoir le voir du haut des
gradins franchement c'est extraordinaire
je veux de la seine-et-marne et quand la
passion le temps de le voir il faut que
les voix fo s'est déplacé ce qu'a avancé
à bombay pour une fois que j'en ai connu
de france
enfin avec les jeunes il joue avec mon
fils tout ça devrait m'aider à la même
équipe donc je suivais sur ce match donc
pensé bord ça fait plaisir
le match s'est terminé par un score de
parité un but partout entre les canet et
les auxerrois on continue à parler de
football ont joué ce week-end le 4e tour
de la coupe de france parmi les
principaux résultats du département le
club de versailles qui évolueront en
nationale 3 s'est facilement imposé 3-0
à l'extérieur contre le club digne d'une
équipe de r4 de son côté le fc mantois
78 a réussi à venir à bout de palaiseau
2 buts à 1 après prolongation voici
également eu besoin d'une prolongation
pour s'extirper du piège tendu par
epinay ce dimanche
le score est digne d'un match de tennis
7 à 5
enfin les mureaux sortent par la petite
porte contre parise ils ont été défaits
1 à 0 le tirage au sort aura lieu à
cette semaine il y avait également du
handball ce week-end avec la deux
journée du championnat de nationale 2
féminine après un bon nul à l'extérieur
l'ouverture contre le psg l'équipe de
montigny le bretonneux a lourdement
chuté sur son terrain contre hazebrouck
ce samedi 23 septembre le score est sans
appel 29 à 23 au niveau du classement
lésigny monteyne pointe à la 10e place
sur 12 équipes avec trois petits points
en rugby à plaisir n'y arrive toujours
pas en fédérale 2 après une première
défaite initiale contre bobigny les
plaisirs roi devait se ressaisir lors de
la 2e journée du championnat
mais les joueurs de sébastien roncalli
se sont inclinés contre drancy à
l'extérieur ce week-end sur le score de
57 à 21 une défaite qui fait mal au
classement les plaisirs oies sont avant
derniers de cette fédérale 2 avec zéro
point inscrit pour le moment une
différence de moins 66 ont continué à
parler à de rugby si on va descendre de
deux divisions pour rejoindre le
championnat honneur le sky rugby est
remonté dans cette division 3 ans après
l'avoir quittée et débutent leur
championnat ce dimanche contre mantes
lit mais pour prendre la température à
l'aube de cette nouvelle saison le
président guillaume payen et le
trois-quarts centre alexandre meunier
sont avec nous en plateau bonsoir genre
alors guillaume le club est en
ébullition on peut le dire à quelques
jours de cette nouvelle saison
on peut le dire on va le dire ce plaisir
on est très content de reprendre
effectivement ça fait trois ans que
qu'on est en promotion honneur par le
pour les seniors et effectivement on a
bien bossé pour pour remonter en honneur
on a bien mérité notre montée donc
maintenant à nous de nous montrer quand
on est bien en honneur et que tout va
bien se passer on a tous travaillé pour
ça en tout les cas depuis le début de la
saison vous avez mangé un petit peu
votre père noir on peut le dire pendant
trois ans et et voilà vous vouliez
absolument remonter et disputer ses
matches de division honneur
oui tout à fait c'était l'objectif du
club depuis que les coaches président
sont arrivés ils ont directement annoncé
leur ambition c'est de revenir en
l'honneur voire plus plus tard dans les
années à venir pourquoi pas attendre la
fédérale 3 on y est enfin cette année on
va tout donner impôts ont baissé de
s'accrocher tout est prêt vraiment pour
faire une grosse saison
quels sont les objectifs déjà du club
l'objectif du club on alex vient de le
dire c'est de monter au niveau fédéral
parce que ça a un impact sur tout tout
reste du club et pas seulement sur
l'équipe senior maintenant pour monter
au niveau fédéral il faut pas juste une
équipe avec 15 joueurs
il faut qu'un club monte au niveau
fédéral et donc sa part les tout petits
des moins de 6 ans jusque jusqu'aux
seniors effectivement et toute la
dynamique qu'on essaye de mettre en
place depuis depuis trois ans bah si on
veut vraiment réussir au niveau fédéral
il faut que tout club progresse donc
entre art on travaille pour ça et les
seniors a pour pour l'effectif là ça
fait depuis fin août on est on est à
fond pour enfin jouer dimanche notre
premier match de division d'honneur et
justement comment vous avez géré
l'intersaison c'est un moment délicat
forcément pour un club
est ce que vous avez voulu conserver les
joueurs qui vous avait emmené jusqu'à la
montée c'était ça l'objectif
même sans monter les autres fois les
autres années lisez c'est que
effectivement tout le monde reste et
parce qu'on travaille donc on construit
des choses et si on a d'autres joueurs
que nouveaux joueurs qui arrivent c'est
super c'est très bien mais il faut
prendre du temps aussi pour les former
pour les construire bien les choses et
que si on regarde tout le monde et qu'on
greffe dessus quelques juniors ce qui
est le cas cette année et quelques
joueurs qui arrivent de l'extérieur
et bah forcément ça va forcément
améliorée améliorer groupe et donc on
est content ce que le noyau dur y
grandit grandit année après année donc
la première année on était tout le temps
25 ans d'entraînement à deuxième ses 33e
5,35 et puis là on continue à continuer
à grandir donc donc ça se passe très
bien ça fait des choix cornélien pour
les coaches voilà c'est très bien c'est
à dire que alexandre comment ça se passe
au niveau du vestiaire cette nouvelle
saison
est ce que vous êtes stressé est ce que
vous avez envie d'en découdre
est ce que vous y allez avec beaucoup de
motivation ouais beaucoup de motivation
on a chargé pendant cinq semaines on a
mangé les entraînements quitte à manger
trois fois par semaine d entraînement
donc là on est vraiment impatient on a
envie d'en découdre dimanche on sait que
ça va être dur ça va piquer maintenant
je vais reprendre qui dédicace des
coachs et lizard pas de nous le dire on
va on va en remettre les remettre nos
bases on va être fort sur nos appuis ont
engagé les pôles et puis on va tout
donner
maintenant on sait que dimanche c'est un
gros morceau qui arrive va falloir
envoyer quoi on parle et d'entraînement
est ce que cette préparation est
peut-être là la pire la plus conséquente
que vous ayez à venir au club au sky
rugby c'est une des plus gros ce que du
pitch arriver
je suis arrivé en même temps que à peu
près et ça c'est une des plus grosses
grosses préparations ils ont commencé
fort avec un gros stage de préparation
dans les bois à fontainebleau
c'était assez solide alors il ya une
nouvelle problématique qui va se mettre
en place cette saison l'année dernière
vous n'avez perdu que deux matches si
mes chiffres sont bons l'année
précédente pareil deux matches cette
année vous forcément vous montez
division vous allez avoir plus de mal à
mon avis à gagner des adhérents contre
est-ce qu'il faut se préparer
psychologiquement à à perdre tout
simplement guillon on va essayer de pas
se préparer à perdre ni
psychologiquement ni sportivement après
après ben oui on fait l'hypothèse que on
a moins de chances de gagner tous les
matchs cette saison que les saisons
passées
maintenant part un peu dans l'inconnu si
on connaît pas très bien le niveau du
championnat honneur
on sait ce qu'on est capable de faire on
sait que groupe il est il est construit
et alexandre parler depuis cinq semaines
il construit depuis trois ans est partie
40 +5 semaines pour être pour être prêt
à tout donc on n'est pas on n'est pas du
tout en accusation on est on est prêt à
tout à gagner surtout et s'il faut
perdre on retombera le dimanche d'après
grand plaisir marquer des points au
championnat
l'objectif c'est vraiment de pérenniser
le club à ce niveau là pas faire
l'ascenseur
exactement il monte en fin de saison si
elle monte ans il faut pas une il ya ce
premier match contre le mans climat qui
arrive du coup ce week-end
qu'est-ce que vous visez sur ce premier
match alexandre ma victoire la victoire
ouais on veut être en reste invincible à
la maison donc à toi si on n'a pas le
choix on sait que ça va être compliqué à
appréhender ce déplacement parce qu'on
apprend on va cergy pontoise
on sait que c'est un autre gros morceau
donc dans tous les cas on est obligé de
gagner ce week-end sinon 120 commence à
tergiverser
mieux vaut gagner d'entrée surprendre un
peu tout le monde de la poule qui nous
qui nous attend peut-être pas ce niveau
c'est l'équipe que vous connaissez ou
pas du tout bio n'est pas du tout bon
connais très peu d équipes dans cette
poule
très très peu de celles qu'on connaît on
les connaît parce qu'on les a joués ya
trois ans que ça a dû tourner aussi nous
ont un peu changé mais ils ont dû
changer aussi et surtout on commence t
elle exploser on commence par les il ya
quand même un classement par rapport au
résultat là se sont passées et on
attaque par les deux équipes les mieux
classées de la poule nom partout 5 0
points mais qu'on fait meilleur
classement en championnat ile de france
l'an dernier pour vous rassure on y va
tranquille on est chez nous on est
contents d'être chez nous et de pouvoir
attaquer à maurepas on invite tout le
monde à venir voir le match parce que ça
va être un gros match dans tous les cas
peu importe le score et on sait que on
sait qu'on sera présent et que pense que
les téléspectateurs sont les bienvenus
je les spectateurs sont dernière
question un pronostic sur cette
rencontre
après je vous laisse je sais c'est dur
non c'est dur je peux pas une victoire
mais victoire du temps on vous le
souhaite en tout cas merci à tous les
deux passés sur ce plateau je le
rappelle pour les téléspectateurs
le prochain match programmé ce dimanche
à 15 heures au stade du bout des clous à
maurepas
je me trompe pas you très bien hameau de
cyclisme à présent à david lappartient
que vous voyez à l'écran est devenu le
troisième français président de l'union
cycliste internationale l'homme de 44
ans a obtenu 37 voix contre 8 pour son
rival le président sortant le
britannique brian coxon auparavant david
lappartient été notamment le président
de la fédération française de 2009 à
il avait son bureau au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
jusqu'en début d'année et son départ de
la ffc événement exceptionnel à
versailles un cours de yoga géant une
discipline qui mêle gymnastique et
spiritualité été donné dans l'orangerie
l'orangerie du château près de 800
personnes ont participé à cet événement
organisé pour récolter des fonds en
faveur de l'association mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque
les images sont signés du très zen
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
cette séance de yoga xxl va permettre de
sauver trois enfants atteints de
problèmes au coeur dans les pays en
développement
baptisé les yogis du coeur l'événement
était organisé ce dimanche 24 septembre
par l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque à l'orangerie du château de
versailles objectifs de la structure
récolter des dons grâce à une action
sportive
je pense que pour un sportif c'est
plaisant de se dire je m'adonne à un
exercice à une action qui me plaît et en
même temps ça va profiter à d'autres
comme on dit aujourd'hui c'est gagnant
gagnant
la séance d'une heure et demie a réuni
près de 700 adultes et une centaine
d'enfants tous et yogi ont versé 25
euros de frais d'inscription
peu importe la séance et on vient pas
tant pour faire le yoga puisque pour
partager ce moment et essai
et sponsorisé le mécénat du coeur oui
c'était un rendez vous important parce
que c'est un moment de partage et qu'on
sait que c'est pour la bonne cause et
dans un lieu extraordinaire
d'autres jodie du coeur seront
organisées dans les grandes villes
françaises le prochain rendez-vous en
ile-de-france est programmée le 17
décembre prochain au palais des congrès
de paris
je vous propose à présent de découvrir
un sport peu connu du grand public
français le padel ce sport d'origine sud
américaine
ou plutôt amérique centrale et ultra
populaire en espagne et il compte
aujourd'hui plusieurs milliers d'adeptes
en france pour nous parler de cette
discipline le responsable du padel club
de bois d'arcy mais libération est avec
nous bonsoir bonsoir alors rapidement
mellick quelles sont les règles du padel
alors le paddle c'est un sport qui se
joue à deux contre deux on est sur un
terrain qui entourait de vitré de
grillage qui fait 20 mètres de long 10
mètres de large
séparés par un filet est le but du jeu
est d'envoyer la balle dans le camp
adverse qu'elle retombe sur le sol et
les adversaires doivent la renvoyer dans
le terrain opposée de plusieurs façons
soit volée comme au tennis soit après le
rebond sur le sol soir bon sol puis
vitres ou parois latérales soi même on
peut aller jusqu à taper dans les vitres
du fonds pour l'envoyer dans le terrain
adverse
donc c'est un sport qui nécessite du
coup de raquette comme comme au tennis
c'est semblable au tennis ou plus à la
pelote basque quand on voit les rebonds
sur sur les parois par exemple quand on
parle de padel on dit que c'est à peu
près 70 % tennis 30% squash plus tôt on
joue avec une raquette qui fait à peu
près 40 cm de long pour 4 cm d'épaisseur
ce qui nous permet d'avoir un très beau
contrôle de la balle est donc même pour
les plus débutants commencé à faire des
échanges assez rapidement et vite
s'amuser et c'est ça la grosse
particularité du paddle c'est que même
si on n'a jamais fait de sport de
raquette
on peut rapidement commencé à jouer et
s'amuser et après si on veut jouer de
façon plus sérieuse est une très très
grosse marge de progression et on est
tous très très loin surtout en france
donc il faut une raquette et une balle
pour jouer sans compter la location du
terrain combien ça coûte concrètement si
on veut se lancer dans le panel a dans
sa chair
c'est pour l'instant il ya beaucoup de
structures privées et aussi les
structures municipales
en général les structures privées
accueille entre entre 5 et 12 terrains
couverts en général les structures
publiques ont en général deux terrains
découverts un abonnement annuel sur une
structure publique on compte aux
alentours des 300 euros maintenant vous
jouez sur deux terrains découverts donc
a pas possibilité de jouer toute l'année
à cause de la météo
dans le privé on est plus sur un tarif
environnant les 10 euros de l'heure par
personne donc ça va dépendre en fait de
la delà du temps que vous voulez jouer
par semaine ça va dépendre en fait voilà
c'est ça qui va vous coûter plus ou
moins dans une secte ur une structure
privée mais au moins vous pourrez jouer
toute l'année donc d'après ce que vous
avez expliqué la balle sort finalement
très peu du terrain voilà il faut tout
encourir être en activité
est ce que ce sport et est complet alors
il est assez complet et il est surtout
ouvert vraiment à tout ce sont là des
jeunes de 15 ans qui viennent jouer et
des personnes de 65 ans aussi du fait
qu'on joue à deux sur un terrain de 20
mètres de long 10 mètres de large
on se partage chacun un couloir qui fait
5 mètres de long 10 mètres de long
puisque moins cinq mètres de large et
dix mètres de long est donc en fin de
compte avec un peu de technique plus on
a de la technique moi on va se déplacer
donc c'est pour ça qu'on peut faire des
parties qui vont durer 1h30 2h il sans
pour autant être sur les rotules à la
fin du match
maintenant plus niveau monte plus les
points vont durer longtemps plus les
échanges vont être
passionnant mais surtout stressant et
dans ce cas là c'est vrai que ça devient
plus facile quand ça devient fatiguant
alors je le disais précédemment dans mon
introduction l'espagne enfin le paddle
en espagne est un sport ultra populaire
deuxième sport le plus populaire
derrière football pourquoi en france la
mayonnaise ne prend pas comme en espagne
alors ce qui s'est passé en espagne fin
des années 90 c'est l'ancien premier
ministre qui a été fan de paddle le
padel et qui n'arrêtait pas de jouer et
qui passait donc sur les magazines de
l'époque qui arrêtaient pas d'en parler
et c'est lui en fait qui a été le
premier ambassadeur en espagne et qui
l'a fait connaître dans toute l'espagne
ça a commencé fin des années 90 et
aujourd'hui on compte plus de quatre
millions de joueurs en espagne et je
crois qu'il ya plus de 30000 cours de
paddle en espagne plus de 40000 même en
france on n'a pas eu encore de grands
ambassadeurs la fédération française de
tennis l'a récupéré à récupérer le
paddle et le gère depuis à peu près deux
ans deux ans et demi
c'est la raison pour laquelle s'est pas
encore assez développé aujourd'hui en
france on coûte à peu près 500 concerts
en cours de paddle mais il ya un an on
en comptait 350 donc on s'en va un vrai
un réel engouement en fait pour le sport
il ya plus en plus de joueurs pareils
fin 2016 d'inscrits mois fin 2015 on
comptait quinze mille joueurs de paddle
aujourd'hui on en compte à peu près
entre 20 et 25 millions qu'on y'a une
une progression nous mêmes au club quand
on a ouvert il ya un an et demi on avait
à peu près 30 joueurs de paddle le
premier mois et aujourd'hui on a à peu
près entre 150 et 200 joueurs qui
viennent jouer au centre et un
engouement même dans votre club qui a
ouvert en 2000 16 ans et qui a ouvert en
2007 sortait l'engouement qui arrivent
dans votre club
on sent l'engouement parce que les
joueurs qui sont venus jouer en 2016
continue de jouer en 2017 pour la
plupart d'entre eux est
ces derniers mois on a on a chaque mois
à peu près des nouveaux joueurs qu'on
intègre avec nous avec qui on fait jouer
qu'on mélange avec des niveaux parfois
différent parfois homogène on n'organise
pas mal d'événements justement pour ces
gens là se sentent intégrés puis trouver
d'autres joueurs et puissent s'amuser et
surtout progresser et je vois de plus en
plus pâles et il ya des tournois qui
sont organisés en france également
et dans le club alors dans le club bien
sûr mais sur toute la france aussi il y
avait notamment les championnats de
france que les finales qui ont eu lieu
le week-end dernier dont il y avait 30
régions représentées au départ avec
seize régions sur place pour les finales
et d'ailleurs c'est les régions du sud 1
midi pyrénées qui ont gagné parce que
eux du fait qu'ils ceux qui sont plus
proches de l'espagne connaissent le
paddle depuis plus de temps que nous et
peuvent jouer des coudes longtemps
qu'ils ont des meilleurs joueurs que
nous encore aujourd'hui mais peut-être
que ça va changer dans peu de temps
dernière question est ce que vous pensez
qu on en est qu'au début l'engouement
pour ce sport
je pense réellement que que c'est un
sport qui va rester je pense pas que
c'est un effet de mode
donc oui oui je pense qu'on est au début
de l'engouement on verra ça en quelques
années dans quelques mois
merci mais liquide est revenu sur ce
plateau pour parler du panel où c'est
évidemment que ce sport se développe
encore plus dans léa prochaines années
avant de passer à notre page agenda
sport automobile la saison 2017 c'est
terminé pour william bertrand par une
quatrième place au meeting
saint-amand-montrond
conséquence le pilote de 15 ans
terminent à la quatrième place du
championnat de france juniors à un point
du podium mais à saison du prodige n'est
pas encore terminé il va pouvoir
réaliser son second test en monoplace f4
l'antichambre de là f1 sur le circuit du
mans le rendez vous est programmé le 24
novembre prochain
on passe maintenant notre rubrique
agenda
[Musique]
on commence cet agenda par de la boxe le
verrez roi ahmed el moussaoui va monter
sur le ring le 14 octobre prochain à
19h30 au zénith de paris
le sportif de 27 ans combattra contre
l'américain john arne riise dans la
grande soirée la conquête grand
rendez-vous de cette fin d'année en
france
il boxera entre en 12 secondes pour
remporter un titre continental comme
vous pouvez le voir sur ces images il
est en pleine préparation
après 30 combats ahmed el moussaoui
compte 26 victoires 1 nul et 3 défaites
son adversaire ne lui qu aux rencontres
fait que dix combats et a remporté à
cette victoire on termine par du
cyclisme un peu moins d'un an après
l'incroyable record de robert marchand
105 ans sur la piste du vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
autre seigneur va tenter de repousser
les limites du corps humain dans
l'enceinte sportive
jeannette augusto 80 ans originaire de
vesoul se lancera sur la piste ce samedi
30 septembre pour établir un record du
monde de l'heure féminin des plus de 80
ans la sportive portera pour l'occasion
le maillot de l'os et vélizy 78 devant
le public
47 ans après avoir réalisé pour le club
le record de france sur piste du 500 m
départ arrêté
jeannette espère réaliser une moyenne de
28 km heure pendant son record pour cela
elle s'entraîne tous les deux jours en
réalisant des séances entre 45 et 50 1
km c'est la fin de ce circuit de sport
merci l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro 10 il a
passé une excellente semaine sportive
sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]